un parc des princes bondé pour la
rencontre lyon marseille
après quatre heures de course trois
porsche sont en tête
pour une politique de la famille avec
quatre objectifs immédiats
la polémique continue faut-il
transférait pétain à domont
mais à messieurs bonsoir voilà donc un
journal décalé un journal en deux temps
une édition à 19h45 une autre à 20h45
la raison vous la voyez maintenant
paraît d'ailleurs moi le parc des
princes dans un quart d'heure tout juste
23 acteurs sur le terrain un arbitre
onze lyonnais et onze marseillais c'est
la finale de la coupe de france de
football
antenne 2 retransmet le match
intégralement et en direct
deuxième événement du samedi c'est
encore un événement sportif les 24
heures du mans depuis maintenant près de
quatre heures deux cent cinquante mille
spectateurs regardent tournée des
voitures 55 très exactement tout de
suite le point sur la course avec
jean-michel leulliot
m
peut-être tourner en 3 minutes 55 et il
s'agit en l'occurrence en première
position d'une porsche celle de 6,29 une
porsche prototypes qui ont bon en
deuxième position une deuxième page
celle de bart et just en troisième
position de 3ème porsche deux hommes
l'un est chauve ti en quatrième position
il mirage celle de la fosse migaud en
équipage français en cinquième position
la seconde mirage celle de derek bell
berne subban est en sixième position
pour l'instant l'alpine renault turbo de
jabouille et patrick tambay sethalpine
rôle de donner quelques soucis elle
n'arrête pas d'en revenir au classement
puis de rétrograder elle s'arrête mais
enfin pour l'instant plus passent à peu
près bien pour elle certains la donnait
battus d'avancé après presque quatre
heures de course et bien elle est encore
là le temps comme beaucoup elle
et toujours plan d'ici sont des 24
heures du mans il fait une chaleur
torride et de très nombreux spectateurs
sont venus assister à cette course qui
est pour l'instant un peu monotone
peut-être comme on espère que d'ici à la
fin de la journée quand la nuit viendra
et la fraîcheur en même temps eh bien
les choses vont un peu s'animer et les
voitures accéléré leur rythme parce
qu'elles sont à près de 20 secondes en
dessous de leur temps des essais elle
tourne en ce moment à 208 km heure de
moyenne alors qu'elle avait réalisé pour
l'alpine turbo en tout cas 230 au cours
de ces séances de jean-michel leulliot
s'appelait pour la circonstance gérard
mary gorée puis deux autres grands
titres sportifs sur lesquels nous
reviendrons dans notre deuxième édition
dans une heure la victoire de philippe
chez jim on dit dans le tour d'italie
c'est sa troisième victoire dans le giro
et puis la finale de roland garros
demain à rolle salomone et adriano
panatta ont gagné aujourd'hui leur
domicile
la famille à l'honneur ce matin un
congrès celui d'une afflux l'union
nationale des associations familiales
un orateur le président république et
quatre objectifs pour valéry giscard
d'estaing une simplification des
prestations familiales dès l'année
prochaine peut-être une allocation
unique un statut social des mères de
famille
le développement des horaires variables
et du travail à temps partiel
enfin une nouvelle politique du logement
quatre objectifs et une philosophie
le gouvernement se prononce clairement
aujourd'hui en faveur d'une politique
globale de la famille il souhaite
déclencher un réflexe familiale chez
tous les responsables mais aussi chez
tous les français il souhaite que dans
notre pays sensibles sinon à la mode du
moins à la faveur des idées l'idée de
famille soit ressenti éprouvé extreme et
comme étant une des idées force de notre
temps
après la famille demain le souvenir pour
le président il s'agit cette fois de
rendre hommage aux combattants de verdun
c'était il ya 60 ans à la tête des
troupes françaises d'un général devenu
maréchal et dont le nom ne peut jamais
être prononcé dans la sérénité
le maréchal pétain nous l'avons encore
constatée le mois dernier avec les
dossiers de l'écran pépin à nouveau à
verdun le dossier de raymond tortora
philippe pétain est né à
cauchy-à-la-tour en 1856 mort à l'île
d'yeu en 1951 à l'âge de 95 ans que
retiendra l'histoire pétain maréchal de
france vainqueur de la bataille de
verdun en 1916 où pétain condamné à mort
et à l'indignité nationale pour trahison
le 15 août 1945 trente ans après le
foyer n'est pas encore éteint
périodiquement quelques brûlot vienne le
ranimer
trente ans après on se demande toujours
si le dossier pétain pas encore d'un
poids politique
pétain pour plus de la moitié des
français c'est de l'histoire et non pas
du bic
il y a 6 français sur 10 qui ignore que
pétain commandé un verbe et il y à plus
d'un français sur deux qui ignore que
pétain était chef de l'état en 1940 le
transfert des cendres du maréchal à
douaumont serait-il considéré comme un
geste de réconciliation nationale ou est
il des conséquences électorales bonne ou
mauvaise pour celui qui prendrait la
ligne en fait quand l'électeur se décide
il se décide très rarement sur un seul
enjeu politique et je n'ai pas
l'impression que l'enjeu transfert ou
non des cendres à douaumont pèserait
lourd dans la décision que beaucoup
d'électeurs
il pourrait gagner renforcer dans des
attitudes majoritaire les catégories qui
sont plus attachés à la figure de pépins
des agriculteurs les personnes âgées
il faudrait
créer un sentiment d'hostilité
les amis de celui qui prendrait la
décision dans des milieux militants
contre pétain notamment les anciens
résistants combattants
il y a moins de droits semaine les
dossiers de l'écran raviver la querelle
des manifestants envahissaient le siège
de la télévision l'émission été retardé
d'une heure et devait se faire d'un
autre studio que celui initialement
prévu
fait exceptionnel le débat devait se
poursuivre jusqu'à une heure du matin
soulevant dans la france entière des
torrents de passion pour ou qu'on le
général de gaulle mise à part puisque
partie prenante dans la sphère pétain on
peut alors se demander pourquoi georges
pompidou et valéry giscard d'estaing
n'ont pas voulu ou pas osé prendre la
décision du transfert des cendres du
maréchal keitel moment où il avait
souhaité reposer parmi ses soldats
parce que le transfert signifier plus
que la réconciliation nationale il
signifiait une sorte d' amnistie et que
l'opinion n'est peut-être pas encore mûr
pour la mystique un quart des français
pensent que pétain était un traître
liban ne parlons pas de lueur d'espoir
dans un pays qui a déjà vu une dizaine
de cessez-le-feu violée mais disons
qu'il y ait un certain dégel le blocus
syrien autour de beyrouth semble se
relâche
lui
virage freinage et c'est après c'est le
plus de courses et goodyear est devenu
le choix des champions il existe aussi
un pneu goodyear pour la route pour la
pluie pour les virages pour les
freinages
si comme les champions vous pouviez
essayez vos pneus vous choisiriez
probablement le g8 sans plus s goodyear
quand une ville un village ont les
moyens de s'équiper
on y vit de mieux en mieux alors pour
aider les villes les villages s'équiper
agrandir la kek lance des emprunts tous
les jours grâce à ses empreintes
laquelle permet à des communes de france
de mieux vivant
emprunt villes de france des emprunts
permanents dont le taux actuariel brut
est fixé chaque mois
je suis resté bien coiffée vous ne
trouvez pas et pourtant je n'ai pas
l'air d'avoir de la lacc
c'est depuis que j'utilisais lurel
allure elle s'est à nouveau produit
ça se met comme une laque mais la
différence c'est qu'on ne sent rien
quand on touche ses cheveux c'est un peu
comme si les cheveux tenait son produit
c'est vraiment bien allure l allure elle
une nouvelle façon de maintenir la
coiffure à lurel delned soyez bloopers
ménages n'avaient avec ronit au lit ses
éclatants
oui c'est tout
oui lave à l'eau froide en toute
sécurité sans retrait se rétrécir s'en
tenir les couleurs pètent comme
survivent à temps utilisé au gîte
mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
bonjour ici le stade du quart des
princes à paris pour la 59ème finale de
la coupe de france qui va opposer sous
vos yeux et en direct sur ces images de
pire ben allel l'équipe de l'olympique
de marseille à l'équipe de l'olympique
lyonnais
une finale des équipes chevronnées
bonsoir nous revoilà donc ensemble pour
une dizaine de minutes le temps de
développer un certain nombre de type que
nous n'avons pas eu le temps d'aborder
en profondeur tout à l'heure surtout des
titres sportifs d'ailleurs si l'on
excepte la finale de la coupe de france
de football
0 0 à la mi temps le deuxième événement
du week end a pour cadre le mans tout de
suite un nouveau point avec jérôme et
ringo favori de ces 24 heures sont
encore en course et au plus haut du
classement ce sans connaître pour
l'instant le moindre incident et penche
au cul
dans l'ordre la voiture numéro 20 le
prototype turbo 2 x 20 mm en deuxième
position le second prototype turbo de
joe dumars troisième une voiture vide
silhouette c'est à dire une grand
tourisme très spécial la carrera turbo
de schollen et shorty en quatrième
position figure maintenant l'alpine
renault de jabouille tambay et deux
voitures se maintient très bien et
aurait même tendance à revenir sur celle
de tête
enfin ce sont les mirages qui occupent
les cinquième et sixième places avec
dans l'ordre la fosse nidau et derek
bell vern schuppan 47 voitures restent
encore en course si l'on peut considérer
cela comme une surprise
tout d'abord retenir la chaleur aurait
dû perdre davantage de ravages
on se croirait au grand prix du brésil
tellement il a fait chaud et les
spectateurs venus plus nombreux que
l'année dernière
verrait d'un bon oeil quelques gouttes
leur tomber sur la tête
les bouteilles de bière des innombrables
buvette se vendent à un rythme fou et il
faut faire d'interminables queues aux
rares fontaine qui vendent le circuit
pour se désaltère ensuite eh bien c'est
la moyenne de la courbe ce que l'on
pourrait qualifier de sénatoriales en
ressort tout de même à près de 208 km
heure quatre heures et demie après le
départ un train qui comme vous pouvez le
constater
hier au pilote
temps de s'amuser si ce n'est sur la
longue ligne droite des hunaudières qui
pêchent me rappelle près de sept
kilomètres pour se relaxer en attend
maintenant les impressions de
oui sera la bienvenue aussi bien pour
les pilotes les mécaniques et pour les
spectateurs
autre grand moment sportif les demi
finales des internationaux de france en
tennis à roland garros avec d'ores et
déjà la fiche de demain ce sera une
finale
solomon panatta jean marc et le mexicain
raul ramirez ici a tout d'abord bataillé
pendant trois heures et demie face à
l'américain harold solomon il mena 4 2
au cinquième set mais comme aux
précédents solomon parvint à égaliser à
4-4 puis à prendre les deux jeux
suivants victoire de solomon dans cette
demi finale 6-7 6-0 4-6 6-4 6-4
nous allons voir la balle de match voilà
un rôle de solomon rencontrera demain en
finale l'italien adriano panatta panatta
avait éliminé les fuseaux aborde en
quart de finale ils pouvaient cet
après-midi redouté l'américain eddie
dips crocodiles du court comme son
copain solomon panatta chemise verte au
service ici allé s'imposer plus
nettement que prévu devant l'ifsi gênés
par la puissance du service de l'italien
et par ses montées à la volée dips a été
débordé par le rythme supérieur imposé
par panatta il n'a pu soutenir cette
cadence au troisième set dips revin
pourtant de 0,3 à 4-4 comme et devant la
grande foule de roland garros et sur un
central surchauffé
il a été battu 6 3 6 2 6 4
belle victoire la de panat tam et
solomon demain sera plus durable
un coup de chapeau aux exploits
solitaire d'abord celui du belge un char
qui vient de prendre la tête de paris
strasbourg en marche il vient de passer
à nancy place stanislas
et puis celui du français esclassan qui
vient de remporter la troisième étape du
midi libre
enfin surtout celui d'italiens gimondi
qui pour la troisième fois remporté le
giro
surprise en effet au tour d'italie dans
la dernière étape disputée contre la
montre à milan felice gimondi abattu le
jeune belge 2 min leader juge est
inattaquable de ce giro à 34 ans gimondi
demeure donc un grand champion qui sur
sa lancée maintenant tenter de courir
une fois encore le tour de france au
classement de cette étape c'est le belge
bruyère qui s'est montré le plus rapide
sur les 28 km gimondi abattu deux mines
de 44 secondes c'est donc avec 19
secondes d'avancé sur la révélation 2min
que gimont dit à remporter son troisième
tour d'italie mexes a terminé 8e sur les
routes
écrasée de soleil du midi libre les
jeunes courent en français s'affirme à
la mêlée a encore bien défendu son
maillot sang et or et vallées ou vieux
hinault attendent comme lui sans trop
d'inquiétude le verdict de l'étape
contre la montre qui demain après-midi
désignera le vainqueur final
aline thévenet remis de sa chute compte
une minute 8 secondes de retard mais il
ne se tient pas battu pour autant
aujourd'hui à béziers 25 coureurs ont
disputé un sprint lancé de très loin et
jacques esclassan vainqueur de hinault
et valet a confirmé sa place de premier
sprinter
paris strasbourg à la marche m'appelant
au contrôle à nancy place stanislas sert
un char qui se présente le premier il a
rejoint et dépassé dans la ville alomene
qui avant de reprendre la route devra
prêter longuement son dos aux mains des
masseurs un char déjà vainqueur de
l'épreuve en 73 et 74 fait désormais
figure de grandissime favori qui peut
l'inquiéter alomene semble désormais
aucun handicapé le français travaillent
manquera vraisemblablement de résistance
est lui et paiera sa débauche d'effort
initial
le strasbourgeois jacques proulx doyen
de ce 50e paris-strasbourg rendu encore
plus inhumain à cause de la chaleur est
trop loin tout comme roland anxionnat
cinquième au passage à tout fonctionne à
victime d'une insolation arrête regarder
mais ils gardent de bons espoirs pour la
suite de la compétition
à l'apollo sport avant de rejoindre le
parc des princes un coup d'oeil sur la
météo de demain une situation
encourageante pour la température ce
devrait être à peu près du même ordre
beaucoup aujourd'hui sauf dans le quart
nord-est en légère baisse
un petit peu moins encourageantes pour
le ciel il y aura des ondes et dans le
nord et dans le nord-est
et puis des orages en montagne partout
ailleurs du soleil pour la fin de ce
journal en deux parties dans deux
minutes là reprise du match et pour ceux
qui ont pris ce journal en cours un
rappel des titres à la mi-temps lyon 0
marseille 0
x-man la nef sur forge toujours en tête
le président pour une politique globale
de la famille le dernier journal ce soir
à 23h25